انضماليه من تل ابيب اور هيلر المراسل
العسكري للقناه الثالثه عشر الاسرائيليه
اور هيلر اذا هي ميني جرونز لم تلحق
اضرارا كبيره في هذا المصنع ولكن ما
الرساله من اسرائيل لايران
لما تتبنى هذا الهجوم الليله على اصفهان
وعلى المصنع لتصنيع الصواريخ البالستيه
ولكن نتذكر انه وفقا للمصادر الايرانيه
ومصادر حزب الله اسرائيل استخدمت هذه
الطائرات المحمله
بالمتفجرات
واستهدفت ايران وحزب الله في السابق اعتقد
ان الرساله هي ان الموساد وجيش الدفاع
الاسرائيلي هي الاولانيه
لايران تصل الى القنبله النوويه او الى
تطوير صواريخ يمكنها ان تحمل رؤوسا نوويه
وتستهدف اسرائيل اعتقد ان هذه الحوامات
المتفجره قامت بما يمكن ان تقوم به وهي
وهو ان تدمر هذا المصنع للصواريخ
البالستيه في اصفهان وهذه الرساله واذكركم
انه في خلال عطله نهايه الاسبوع الماضيه
مدير الوكالات الاستخبارات المركزيه
السياسيه
زار اسرائيل
للتنسيق
لتنسيق الانشطه ضد طهران وودوا اذكر ايضا
بالتدريب الكبير بين سلاحين الجو
الاسرائيلي والامريكي الاسبوع الماضي وهذا
التدريب والمناورات
الى محاكاه هجوم يستهدف منشات نوويه
ايرانيه
همم كما سمعنا قبل قليل من مدير مكتب
الجزيره في طهران هذه ليست المره الاولى
الذي يستهدف فيها هذا المصنع ما هي
معطياتكم لماذا الاصرار تحديدا
توكينج باودر
بشكل رسمي يقولون انه مركز الفضاء
الايراني في اصفهان ولكن وفقا للمعلومات
الاستخباريه الغربيه نحن نتحدث عن مصنعا
لتصنيع الصواريخ البالستيه في اصفهان
وطبعا
الايرانيون لديهم ما يكفي من يورانيوم
خاصه بالانتاج قنبله نوويه
اللعبه الجديده اذا ما صحت تعبير هي تقضي
بمن نعي الايرانيين من استخدام الصواريخ
البالستيه لحمل رؤوس النوويه حيث ان وفقا
للاستخبارات الاسرائيليه سوف يتطلب همم
سنتين من الوقت للوصول الى هذا الامر
الرساله هي عند الاتفاق النو ليس على
الطاوله طبعا الايرانيون يساعدون الروس
يساعدون بوتا من خلال الطائرات المسيره
وربما الصواريخ في المستقبل ضد اوكرانيا
وبالتالي اعتقد ان الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه واداره بيضا على وجه الخصوص
تعرب عن جاهزيتها
لاظهار القوه في منطقه الشرق الاوسط
وخصوصا في ايران ولكن ايضا اعتقدوا ان
السعوديه
وبانه ايران تزود روسيا بالمسيرات اذا
هناك رساله ايضا اسرائيليه لروسيا من خلف
هذه العمليه
الاسبوع الاسبوع
التاسع
خصوصا مع تواجد
القوات الجويه الروسيه في سوريا
اخر نحن نتحدث هنا عن جهد الاسرائيليه
الامريكيه مشترك لمنع ايران من الاستحواذ
على القنبله النوويه
وتل ابيب عن ما سماها طرقا جديدا لاحتواء
طموحات ايران العسكريه ما هي هذه الطرق
الجديده
هذه الطرق الجديده والوسائل الجديده هي
انه هو للمره
الاولى البيبي 52 الامريكيه وايضا هذه
القاذفات الامريكيه مع قوات الجوق السلاح
الجو الاسرائيلي
مشتركه
هجوما على منشات النوويه ايرانيه هذه
المناورات كانت الاولى من نوعها لم تكن
سرا واا شاهدنا
التغطيه الاعلاميه الامريكيه لهذه
الملورات والقياده الوسطى الامريكيه تحدثت
عن هذا الموضوع ونشرت تفاصيل محدده حول
هذه المناورات العسكريه المشتركه بين
الولايات المتحده واسرائيل وبالتالي هذه
سياسه جديده من قبل اداره الرئيس بعدما
جايبل توشيبا الامل همم
بعدم التمكن من خطه العمل الشامل المشتركه
شكرا لك اور هيلر المراسل العسكري للقناه
الثالثه عشر الاسرائيليه